yo this is Mike Williams or you might
know me on social as yo Remy so I
thought quite a few marketplaces in the
past and probably one of the more
notable ones studio time which is an
Airbnb for music studios most of the
MVPs I build are without code and using
share tribes hosted marketplace solution
which is turnkey so I'm gonna make a
brief tutorial right now first I want to
walk you through setting up an initial
marketplace using share tribes hosted
platform and it's great for creating an
initial MVP so you can use it for
creating marketplaces for selling
products or goods rentals or services
but for the sake of this to kind of keep
it as close parallel as Airbnb as
possible we're going to go with rentals
and we're actually just gonna call it
studio B&B and pretty much make it a
studio time me to Airbnb alright so
let's go ahead and get started and we're
gonna walk through this right now so I'm
just going to go ahead and put my email
in and select the country and the
language which is actually going to be
that default language for the
marketplace so that's step 2 and I'm
just going to enter my name here so and
then create a password and then as I
mentioned the different marketplace
types they had that share tribes
suitable for his products or goods
rentals or services so we're gonna go
with rental since we're going to do an
Airbnb so we're going to call it Studio
a B&B once again agree to their terms
and then create so this is creating the
marketplace right now alright so let's
see the initial signup process literally
just from going to share drive calm and
just clicking on getting started so it
automatically sets up a marketplace for
me up here I did two previous ones that
had to delete the videos so this is
do BMB - but that would be the RL studio
B&B chair tribe calm and we're going to
close out this little help chat but they
dropped me right into the main admin
dashboard it created a user account for
me up here so that was using my first
name last name email entered and
password and then you can see right here
I have a user account and it's just
selected as an admin so now I'm on the
dashboard so they have a really good
onboarding process right here and we're
just going to go ahead and setup the
marketplace so we're gonna add the basic
information for the marketplace and
right here so the marketplace name was
already entered so that was studio time
same thing up at the language you can
enter multiple languages but I would not
recommend having multiple languages and
in dealing with localization what not
for simply validating an MVP that's
typically not the best thing to do when
you're trying to validate a marketplace
so since this is like a air air B&B for
music studios our slogan is just going
to be find and book music studios there
we go and then the kind of tagline is
just going to be the easiest way to find
in both music videos just keep it simple
and then the search alt text is actually
going to be when you click on the search
icon at the very top and the top nav is
dropped down right here and it says
search is a hint text so you can
actually change that the help text or
hint text so if it's going to be
location or keyword base its best to
kind of pick one and kind of guide your
user through this alt text so I don't
know it search for so we're gonna use
location location as a primary search
solution to say where are you looking
for a studio or where would you like to
make music so we'll just have that and
then you can have require users to
accept an agreement or some kind of text
which I would highly recommend because
this would be where you could say you
know by signing up to the site you agree
to accept the terms privacy policy &
munity guidelines I would also recommend
having Community Guidelines for
marketplace because that's best we'll
just click out so that what you want to
put more text and we'll just save that
right so that that was saved and then
we're gonna click out of this alright so
that was the basic details now we're
gonna click on the design so this is
where we can further configure the
marketplace for studio B&B in our
specific look here so I'm gonna click on
the logo and actually created a quick
little context base logo and snappa
which is a visual design kind of
creation tool like right before I did
this so I just uploaded that I would
also upload it here for a logo for
social sharing for the cover photo which
is going to show on the top area kind of
like a header section of the homepage
I'm just going to go ahead and select an
image of a music studio and then same
thing for the small cover photo so this
is if a user is not logged in when they
come to the home page you can select a
favicon here you can also change the
marketplace color so if right now you
can see that it's like a blue you know
you could change that right here just by
simply entering the hex value same thing
with changing like the slogan color in
the description color and then down here
is where you could change the default
browse for you so when a user goat sees
the homepage and they see listings this
would be the layout or and how they're
displayed so there's three different
options you can't do combinations of
these but you can do a grid a list or a
map right now the currents do your time
site is on share tribes flex platform
which isn't hosted it's on their API and
totally custom front end so it's list
and map view just like Airbnb is a list
in map view but for this invalidating
and MVP the grid view is typically the
best that's the best experience for
users seeing the listings when they come
to the home page I would suggest having
the display names right below it as far
as the metadata being first name with
some initial that way you would see like
Studio listed by in this case like me so
be like Mike W just said it's kind of a
personal touch to the studio and so
we're going to save this we're not going
to add any custom script right now
because we're just setting up the basic
marketplace all right and so we've gone
through the basics of details design we
don't really need to go through doing a
lot of advanced configuration this
that's what I'm gonna do in the next
tutorial but I want to walk you through
just the I would say um start to kind of
fully functional MVP in this first video
top bar is not relevant landing page
isn't really relevant because you can't
configure that in this let's go to
listing categories so if we wanted to
create categories which would be the
different studio types for instance this
is where we could do that because it
doesn't have any kind of categories
except as default so we'll just keep it
default for now because we don't want to
do any kind of advanced configuration
we'll do that in the next video and then
we'll go through the listing filters in
fields so when someone's creating a
listing this is the different fields
that they'll see so this looks good for
now we can just keep it a title a price
detail description an expiration date we
probably don't need this so location and
then images so that's good for now for
the basics
you could add text numbers dropdowns
checkbox groups and dates so you can
totally customize that and then we're
going to go to order types so to speak a
little bit uh spend a little bit of time
talking about this for since this is
like an air beanie for music studios the
value prop is being able to discover and
book music studios through this
marketplace so
they sure trip also accounts for renting
out without online payments or with but
since our value prop for the MVP is
dependent on online payments we're going
to remove this the ability to list a
studio without accepting online payments
there are different use cases for
different business models where that
would totally make sense and it's just
good to know that sure tribe does
account for this and then here's the
drop down where you could add others so
you can have multiple I would say
different order types within a main
marketplace so studio B&B could
potentially also sell products offer
services for producers and engineers we
could create out of the listings for
like requests all sorts of different
listing types but generally you want to
stick to one and validating that these
are just for for you know other people
that are trying to validate other types
of marketplace MVPs and they would
probably you know just use these for
their specific needs
but since as I mentioned we're not going
to allow people to listen to you without
payments we're just going to go down
here and we're going to delete this
order type so we just deleted that so
right now it's just going to be order
types running out with online payment
and we're just gonna modify this a
little bit and I'll explain why so the
name running out without online payment
we don't need this right here it can
just be ringing out music studio because
this is what someone's going to see is
the kind of top level selection when
they click post a new listing so we just
want this kind of text to be intuitive
then they check out button when someone
clicks on the button that's on their
listing we don't want it to say you know
rent or or whatnot or or buy we want to
make it book now so it's a little bit
more a little bit more intuitive call to
action and so since this is a raining
I'll accepting payments we allow an ADD
price select the ability to accept
payments they don't need a shipping fee
since they're not shipping any
any goods or products and then for the
availability this is where this kind of
ties into them having our calendar
availability in that is based off of per
hour day or night since we're not doing
nightly of course it's for Studios we're
going to select to the hour for
availability and that would be our unit
pricing units too so we'll just save
this and we'll go down so the payment
system we're going to click on that so
you can configure the default currency
for your marketplace and then also the
minimum transaction size that's not
really relevant for us we're not really
worried about the minimum transaction
size because we're assuming that the
studio hourly rate if they have hourly
minimums as far as they require certain
amount of hours to further booking to
take place then they can just mention
that in their description so we don't
need to configure that sharetribe does
allow you to use stripe as far as
accepting payments and that would be
through a stripe Connect account or
through PayPal which PayPal has a
marketplace kind of solution and I can
talk about that and in the next video
with configuration but we're not going
to setup either right now because that's
a little bit more it's just it's a
simple kind of Connect entering your
your stripe kind of IDs and then
connecting a PayPal business account so
I don't really need to go through that
it's fairly intuitive we're just going
to kind of keep going through this
initial set up and we'll click on the
social media so we don't really need to
add a twitter username because we're not
going to have any kind of share ability
as far as prompting people to tweet you
can have a facebook off and they make it
super easy to allow for that so it's not
just an email and password and you can
simply enter a facebook client ID and
client secret right here so I don't need
to go set up a Facebook app for Studio B
and B since this is a demo so we're just
going to skip through that also and then
you would have your analytics
here and then we don't need to set that
up that's just like your Google ID and
then they do have like an instruction
text so you can have information here
you can edit and that would just expand
into a text editor as far as hint text
for people to sign up so for instance
you could add some text here that says
you know if you're signing up as a
studio for user account you can add your
studio by clicking posting a listing on
the top left so just to make a little
bit more intuitive as far as for your
users in your marketplace and then we're
going to click down here on the email
configurations and they make it easy to
configure the emails that you're sending
from so this is going to be like the
welcome email and you can also put like
a kind of a brief onboarding email for
new users but this would be like who is
from so if this is like team studio time
it could be like team a studio or studio
B&B you're like team s studio being
being like team at Studio B and be calm
and that's where you would do that right
here and then we're going to go down and
this is our main market place settings
and this is pretty much the last step
that we're going to do to set up the
entire market place MVP for studio B&B
but some different preferences is
allowing you to only join with invites
so if you want to kind of close off the
user registration and take advantage of
some kind of like invites you can do
that a lot in allow all users to invite
others there'd be a field there so we
don't really need this because we're
gonna anyone there is a configuration we
can only allow registered users to see
listings and profiles so it would
basically be a home page at the URL so
like studio B & B you know sharetribe
calm or studio b and be calm and they
never just prompt users to create an
account or login before they saw the
grid view with the listings i wouldn't
really recommend that if you're trying
to share a lot of the new listings and
kind of build some
around your listings on the social
because when when they click on that
link if they're not logged in then it'll
just prompt in the login or create an
account so it's not really like you
can't really get a feel of the
marketplace if you don't have an account
and then something else they have which
is really good is only allowing users
verified by admins to post in your
listing so that could be good if you're
validating your MVP and in this case
studio being b's MVP because I could
only select certain users to be able to
upload a new listing and that way I
would know that they're you know they
would be like an approved user in that
their studio would be you know higher
quality studio listing or you know they
we had some had text that said you know
you know email us and we approve you
know certain profiles or in your
business information we could kind of go
through that that process by clicking on
this so that would only allow certain
users to post new listings if they're
verified so as I mentioned now to the
search preferences you can do keyword
location search or keyword and location
since typically it's by location and and
that's a little bit more intuitive for
users we we put the hint text for
location so we're just going to go ahead
and select that our default is not
kilometers we're gonna be based on the
US it's going to be miles and we don't
want to only show nearby because we're
not gonna have a ton of inventory so we
might as well show it all and then just
the sort based off of you know the
distance we're gonna display the listing
type in in the main view may be
publishing day we don't need that right
now
but if the marketplace is say from since
every year old maybe it would be great
to have beneficial to show the listing
date so that way people could kind of
see what the newest inventory is if
there's no ratings or reviews and it
would understand that maybe it's just a
new listing so it hasn't been booked yet
you can also it does have a common
functionality you sharetribe does have
that so we're just going to allow people
to comment
and maybe create a discussion on each
listing just be aware that it might not
be beneficial for kind of dialogue and
conversation to be going on on listings
so if you notice that you know people
are just commenting instead of messaging
studios or there's any kind of negative
comments about it or whatnot then you
can just simply unselect this and kind
of resave that and then the email
preferences a cool feature that they
also have is this newsletter feature and
kind of functionality so every week
everyone that's signed up would get a
this kind of newsletter format of all
the new listings which i think is really
good in the very beginning so we're
going to go ahead and save these
settings and then now that we've gone
through this kind of entire process of
the basic configuration right so I need
to confirm my email address so I'm going
to do that
so I just click through the email all
right so I should be confirmed in that
other window all right good
some confirmed all right so now we're
just going to go through and look at our
initial marketplace so there's no
listings so we don't have anything right
here and we don't have any filters that
display or anything I could just simply
create one right here we do see this
like hint text and the search that's
already populated and I'm just going to
go ahead and sign out of the admin
account though so that way we can see
what people visitors that come to the
site will see before they create an
account with the intent to book or list
their studio so I'm just going to go
ahead and log out right now all right so
as you can see this is the basic home
page this is actual home page view for
the marketplace so this is empty without
any listings but as you see the cover
that I uploaded the top left has the the
menu it you can expand and then we have
the logo that I uploaded said we don't
have the placeholder blue text anymore
up there we have the natural logo and
then we have our kind of like tagline
right here so so this is the basic
marketplace that usual so you can see
and then we do have like an about right
there
so I'm gonna take you through that
really quick all right
so I
second as a user and I'm of course the
admin right now so I'm going to just go
through and just show you a little bit
more about the admin panel right now and
some of the functionality so in the
marketplace kind of admin management
they have a you can click on this and
see all the users and select uses the
admin you can ban users if you selected
only users with permission could post
this is where it would have another
column right here where you'd be able to
select that so that's definitely a good
feature they have another kind of
listing management view right here so
there's no listings but you'd be able to
see all the listings fight by the
listing title so for instance that'd be
like the studio name the authors are
like who the user is their user name the
creation and then updated date and then
you can see the categories so for
instance if it was like home studio as a
category you'd be able to see all the
home studios and then also the status
you also have a transaction view so you
would be able to see transactions and
then the different states so it'd be
transactions tied to a listing on status
of it as far as like request accepted
completed reviews left and whatnot when
it was started the latest activities
sort by so it makes it really good as
far as like marketplace and kind of user
management who started it and then the
other parties that'd be the person
requesting and then the other party
would be the studio that was being
requested you can actually see the
conversation so you can monitor
conversations that are going on from
user and user so you can see that and
then you can also see all the reviews
down here there's another view for that
and then email users and invite new
users so this is the
basic setup for a Airbnb style
marketplaces for amuse music studios
that we just called studio B&B for the
sake of this initial tutorial but it is
a fully functioning marketplace and
pretty much the same exact kind of
functionality as basic functionality as
Airbnb which would be needed to validate
this MVP as you can see right now this
is our marketplace called studio B&B
which is our Airbnb for music studios
and it's pretty bare and basic so we
need to do a little bit of configuration
and customization so that way you have a
little bit more functionality of
features for that we'll need to validate
this marketplace so we're not logged in
right now so this is what everyone that
comes to the site will see as you can
see that the sign of login in the left
side nav home page and the about page
the about page how it works
privacy policy and Terms of Service this
is all placeholder text that sharetribe
populates on our marketplace so we're
going to need to go in and edit this and
change it so I'm going to show you how
to do that that so imma go ahead and log
in right now all right so we're logged
in as a user and we do have admin
permission so we actually don't do this
from the admin panel for editing the
about page and how it works and those
other pages we're just gonna click on
the actual about page and then you can
see each of them in this kind of left
side you would just simply click on the
edit from each and this takes you to a
on page context editor in at the very
top you have a little bit of
functionality as far as kind of you know
what how you can edit it in what you can
add but we're not going to spend the
time to go through that so we have some
other features that we need to customize
right so let's go over back to the admin
panel all right so now we're in the
admin panel and our basic listing
categories since we're only offering
music studios and then the we're going
to basically have the the different
types of studios as filters that way
that I'll populate on the home page and
we're sticking in music studios we're
not going to add any other kind of main
categories if we were going to be a
studio B&B and we wanted to have for
instance photo studios you know video
studios then we could add other
categories and then that way when you
click on post new listing as the user
that is trying to list their studio you
could select which category of studio
but we're not going that we don't need
to configure that for our MVP so we're
good with the categories we're also the
different fields and filters as I
mentioned so we do need to create a
filter for the different studio types so
the current fields which can also be
filters and this is what the different
text fields that are going to be on the
listing creation process are listing
title price description expiration date
location and image really don't need to
expiration date I'm not going to worry
about removing it though we are going to
add a checkbox group and we're gonna
call that studio type is the title of it
and I can type there we go and so it's
gonna be mandatory when you person
creates a listing and then we're going
to display this on the home page so we
do want that display on the left so it
makes it easy for users to select the
filter as far as which type of suit that
are looking for so we're just going to
stick with two just for simplicity in
this quick tutorial so home studio we're
going to add another so we're going to
add top line studio
all right so those are two you don't
need to set up payments right now
thanks for the prompt so those are two
different types which are going to be
filters on the homepage and then also
for the sake of this tutorial
added a added back in the order type of
renting out without accepting payments
because I can't demo posting a new
listing without doing a the payment
integration so I just out of that so I
can do it kind of quick demo but that's
our basic configuration so let's go back
to the home page we don't have any new
listings but as you can see the studio
type is on the left so you can select
home studio top-line studio and then
we're going to go back to the admin
dashboard
and we are going to add a number and
we're gonna call this price and we're
not gonna make this mandatory but we're
going to display a filter so our minimum
is going to be 10 and our maximum is
going to be what - say 400 and then
we'll just call it price per hour
well hourly rental will be displayed in
the listing so we don't need that so
we're just going to save this and then
we're going to go back to the home page
and as you can see now we have a slider
that's gonna serve as a or act as a
price filter so this can then update all
of our listings so as we start to build
our listing inventory and have you know
ten fifty to a hundred steal a little
singles this will make it really this
will make it really a better user
experience for people to discover the
right studio and then conversions to
bookings so this is the basic
configuration this is actually all we
need to configure and all the kind of
functionality on both ends as the kind
of marketplace adding capabilities and
then also as far as usability from the
user side so now that we have the
initial marketplace set up we need to go
through and do kind of a prep for our
first real users and launch so we need
to make it very intuitive for users that
way they can have the best experience
and we can get a little bit better
feedback and some external validation
for for this MVP so let's go through
right now one of the first things that
we're going to need to do is of course
post a listing so before we try to
onboard new inventory from other people
we should probably create our own and
use a place a placeholder with some kind
of some tips on the listing and that's
what I actually did for studio time when
I right before I initially reached out
to a few of the first studios and I
still actually had the kind of
placeholder listing on there when I when
I launched on product time and then even
when it was picked
by press so we're going to click on post
a new listing and we're gonna do ringing
out without accepting payments because
once again I don't have the payments
integrated yet on this MVP so we would
need to do that before we did launch of
course to because we want our first
inventory of real users to actually
enter their payout information to which
is very simple so we'll just do see your
studio here and then we'll just put a
price we're gonna guess around the price
per our list the ideal kind of range
that we wants to do is to charge per
hour because this is what they're gonna
see as a placeholder so keep that in
mind so we can put 50 if that's about
what the price are we would ideally like
to see so we'll say see your listing
here and I'm not gonna extensively type
this out I'm just going to put the
placeholder and then we would probably
put like tips that we would just list
out a few pics um for like our demo kind
of placeholder listening so studios
could just get a good idea of what they
would need to put probably about in this
use case um you know more about the
space the studio itself the equipment
setup what it's ideally used for and
then any kind of you know specifics for
their studio that others we need in
order to if they were going to be
booking the space we'll just put both
that way if people use filters and then
location will just you Santa Monica
because that's where we are and it
populates a pin so they use Google Maps
as far as for their Maps share chart
does and then we'll go through and we're
just going to select our kind of
placeholder image that we use before
ideally you probably want to have some
kind of a visual image that you create
like in snappa just to make it kind of
look like very well branded and kind of
slick so in this case we could just have
like a background of a studio and then
just like a watermark over the in the
middle of like this
Oh B&B logo or like see your studio here
kind of thing and we're going to go and
post it so yeah so they sure tribes
doing the prompting in for the payments
but we're going to kind of skip over
that step so as you can see I'm logged
in I'm the ability to edit not only my
listing but I could edit any listing
that I click on as an admin so if we do
have a few studios that sign up prior to
us rolling it out to other external kind
of testers or you know prep for a launch
we could go through and edit some of
their listings and just send them a note
saying that we optimized their listing
and that way you have some kind of
consistency in all of our listings we
could upload better images if we find
some for them or what we can also close
listings for instance if they said hey
take my listing down or you know I'm not
running it out anymore we can close any
listing as an admin we can move to the
top and the home page which is this
great feature that sharetribe has so
that way if you know we're speaking with
a studio because it's safe for instance
one of my fern studios and I tell them
that you know we're going to help drive
awareness and we probably want to put
them where they're visible to most so we
can move them to the top if you're going
to charge Studios to sign up and we had
different levels like basic and premium
and part of the premium was being at the
top of all results and listings then we
could of course simply kind of run a
check on our and it would be manual at
first but it would be just seeing like
an iGoogle sheet all the premium
subscriptions or premium studios and
then making sure that they're always at
the top we would also probably want to
show them in a newsletter that goes out
to all users especially kind of during
launch and the you know where we're
gonna get some increase in users and
exposure we could do that by just simply
clicking on this show in the next
newsletter so here's the main listing
and then we'll go back to the home page
and that way we can see an actual
listing now all right so we're logged in
and if we're logged in we're not going
to see the cover once again that's a
link for a logout state
and then we'll see like our listen here
so all those things to populate and it's
an endless scroll so if I mean if you
build up an inventory you know say 20
down it's just an it's an endless scroll
all the way to the bottom so some other
things we'll go to the admin panel
really quick
just to go through and just kind of run
a check on if there's any other kind of
configurations that we we need to do in
order to try to get some external
testing and prep for a launch from
listen Ischl MVP so if we didn't want to
have this on a custom domain or own
domain we would need to upgrade so not
on the free trial so we could just click
on subscription here and that would be
through the share tribe and then we're
not going to need to do any user
management any listing management for
now we're not going to be you know we're
not going to be monitoring any
transactions or conversations for now or
reviews we could potentially email all
users if we did notice that some of the
users from the user management were like
studio domains then we could email users
you know sign up if your studio you can
sign up you know here and add your
listing before we launch kind of thing
you could send out invites that's not
really a function on a I don't think
that Mimi needs to be on the admin panel
but we're good with our basic
configurations once again what we would
need to do is remove the order type of
the ability to listen to do without
payments since that's not what our MVP
this you know that's not beneficial for
for our MVP since part of our value prop
is accepting payments and booking
through our marketplace so we need to
remove that and then we need to do our
stripe and or PayPal integration in this
case we would do both and then we would
just finalize all of our welcome emails
and our hint text in any of the last
kind of settings that we would need in
order to launch but at this point we we
have our basic MVP for studio B&B which
is an Airbnb for music studios we've
gone through the basic setup
we've configured it so we have all the
required functionality and we kind of
went through a lightweight kind of MVP
or product pre-launch and kind of
launched checklist so now we're ready to
get external users and prep for a launch
and try to validate our MVP thanks